[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a russian sports comedy film
called i am losing weight spoilers ahead
watch out hence take care
the movie begins in the city of nizhny
novgorod russia anya is a girl in her
20s living with her bodybuilder and
swimming coach boyfriend zhenya she
works in a bakery and hence is always
working with food when the couple first
met she was a size zero but over the
months she has gained a considerable
amount of weight one day they are called
to a friend's wedding anya tries on
clothes from a few months ago and
realizes that they do not fit anymore
she consoles herself by saying that no
one will notice but the change in her
body is significant zhenya knows this
too but he doesn't want to comment on
how much weight she has gained knowing
that it is a sensitive topic for her
after trying on a few clothes and
ripping some in the process anya finds a
decent one and gets ready when zhenya
gets a look at her in the dress his face
drops in shock she is no longer the girl
he was in a relationship with before he
doesn't want to be seen with her at the
wedding because all of his friends from
the fitness industry will be there he
gives her subtle hints hoping that she
will stay home to his relief anya says
that she wants to stay home and order
pizza she urges him to stay with her but
zhenya promises to congratulate the
newlyweds and return home in an instant
before leaving he picks her up and puts
her on the counter but dodges when she
tries to kiss him anya notices the
gesture but hides the fact that she is
hurt after he leaves she changes into
comfortable clothes and weighs herself
to find out that she is 76 kilos
although she is always complaining about
gaining weight her only resolution is to
drink a glass of water after saying her
daily affirmations even now she cooks
some fried food and scrolls through the
internet while waiting for her boyfriend
while she is on the phone she notices
pictures of zhenya and his friends at
the wedding she zooms into a group
picture and is troubled to see that the
girls jenya hangs out with are skinny
and fit she cannot help but compare
herself to them then she comes across a
picture of zhenya and a girl on checking
her profile she is horrified to see a
boomerang of the girl kissing him on the
cheek the video is enough for anya to
get dressed put on some makeup and rush
to the wedding she calls her best friend
natasha to pick her up natasha also
notices that she has gained weight but
to her anya still looks just as
beautiful she holds her face telling her
to be confident about her body when anya
reaches the venue she sees jenya dancing
with the girl and getting a bit too
close jealousy gets the best of her and
she gets in between them zhenya is
visibly surprised but he continues
dancing as the other girl scoffs and
walks away a while later the couple
takes a seat and anya starts eating she
asks him why he was dancing with a girl
but zhenya tries to pass it off by
saying they were dancing in a group when
anya pushes him he lashes out and admits
that he doesn't like her anymore he adds
that she does nothing but eat and is
turned into a burden for him anya gets
teary but before they can talk the
newlywed couple approaches them they try
to smile but it vanishes when the bride
asks anya if she is pregnant following
that zhenya wishes her farewell and
walks away in the next scene anya is on
a bus on her way to her mother's house
she's crying uncontrollably not caring
what people think of her she walks in on
her mother talking to a date he notices
something is off and walks outside to
give them privacy anya tells her mother
that her boyfriend broke up with her
because of her weight her mother
comments that she is not fat she just
has wide bones that she cannot control
the remark makes her feel a lot worse
than she already did at night she sleeps
on her mother's couch while going
through zhenya's pictures on her phone
she also comes across a picture of
herself from a few months ago she zooms
into her body and is saddened to see how
much she has changed the next morning
she gets a call from natasha who asks
her to come over anya takes a bed on
natasha's balcony and stays there
complaining about the breakup it turns
out that jenya had come there the
previous evening to drop off all of her
belongings natasha asks her to stay with
her and her husband dimas for a few days
until she finds her own place she tries
to comfort her friend but anya doesn't
want to feel better she only wants to
cry and complain about her lousy
ex-boyfriend who she wants to get back
together with even dimas tries to make
her feel better claiming that she is the
sexiest girl in the town but it does
nothing to help anya she spends the
night on the balcony and is approached
by natasha the next morning natasha
tells her the story about a friend who
was in the same position as anya her
boyfriend broke up with her over text
because she had gained weight instead of
bitching and moaning like anya the girl
went to the gym and got slim in only a
month the poor boyfriend regretted his
decision so much that he filled her
office with flowers to ask her to get
back with him when anya complains that
she doesn't have enough money to join a
gym natasha suggests she used the one
week free trial in all gyms in the town
and do it for free the next morning anya
says her morning affirmations drinks a
glass of water and goes to the gym for
the first time in her life she takes a
while to get accustomed to the equipment
and falls off the treadmill on several
occasions but all of her hard work goes
to waste because an hour later she is at
a restaurant eating for two natasha who
works in the restaurant throws her food
away disappointed that she couldn't
commit for more than two hours she asks
her friend to show some willpower on
returning home anya applies moisturizer
all over her body and wraps it with
plastic wrap she hopes that the trick
will make her lose a few pounds while
devouring a bag of chips at midnight she
tries to steal food from the
refrigerator but is caught by natasha
the next day she is determined to not
eat anything unhealthy this is
especially difficult for her because she
works in a bakery while decorating a
cake she accidentally licks icing off
her fingers and does 10 squats to make
up for it throughout the day food calls
her name but she controls herself at one
point she is left alone with an entire
cake she stares at it for several
minutes trying to make up an excuse to
eat it after pacing around and almost
breaking a shelf she gives up and
devours half of the cake at once anya
realizes that she has a problem she
looks for a self-help group for people
with a compulsive eating disorder and
joins a meeting amidst the group of
ladies is a single man named colia anya
introduces herself as angela and lies
that she doesn't have an eating disorder
instead she claims to be a journalist
who is writing a story on eating
disorders the group tries to reason with
their condition not accepting the fact
that they have a problem an infuriated
colia points at each of them and calls
them all fat including himself he also
says that it is obvious anya lied about
being a journalist because she doesn't
want to accept that she has a problem
anya pretends to get a phone call and
leaves the meeting but kollia follows
her he invites her to a nearby
restaurant and anya goes only because
she cannot say no to food colia proposes
they become each other's fitness
sponsors that way they have to exercise
with each other daily ask each other
before eating anything and provide
emotional support throughout the process
anya is unsure about kolya's true
intentions but she sees no harm in
trying starting the next day they go to
a park every morning to run at first
anya is reluctant to be with kolya but
as time passes she realizes that he is
actually a nice person he is not ashamed
of what his body looks like which is
foreign to her spending time with him
makes her love her body as well they
talk before every meal and are good at
helping each other since they're going
through the same problem soon anya
starts to lose weight little by little
her confidence wavers when she goes to
pool parties and sees skinny girls
looking gorgeous whenever she feels
frustrated collia helps her they
frequently scream at the top of their
lungs to relieve stress anya wants
nothing but zhenya's validation which
makes kolya jealous in one and a half
months she drops down to 10 kilos and is
ready to meet jenya again she buys a
swimsuit and pretends to bump into him
at a swimming pool he works as an
instructor and is stunned to see her
after chatting for a while they get into
the pool and start splashing water at
each other everything goes well until
the girl from the wedding arrives and
introduces herself as jenny's girlfriend
anya is heartbroken for the second time
she parties and drinks all night to
forget about him the following morning
she wakes up naked in kolya's bed he
assures her that he did not look at her
naked a flashback from the other night
shows us that anya was about to go home
with a stranger but kolya arrived at the
right time and took a punch to the face
to save her following the strange
morning she goes to her mother's house
and tells her everything according to
her mother anya has unresolved trauma
from her father who left them when she
was only a kid hence she wants zhenya's
validation even though he is not good to
her anya understands what she means and
goes to meet her father the very next
day she takes kolya as her driver
because the drive is five hours long on
their way kolja often tries to get
closer to her showing that he likes her
but anya is oblivious to his advances
they finally meet her father sergey in a
wooden house where he lives with a woman
anya asks him why he didn't want to be
involved in her life sergey on the other
hand reminds her of the time he came to
her birthday with a present but she
flipped him off through the window at
night anya accidentally drops a candle
and lights the wooden house on fire
sergey yells at her for ruining his
house not caring about her safety anya
and kolya return home immediately after
before separating she kisses him on the
nose colia is on top of the world on his
ride home he even trades his watch to
buy flowers for her somewhere else
zhenya comes to meet anya and apologizes
to her they end up making love after
talking for a while when colyer returns
with the flowers he sees them and walks
away disappointed the next morning anya
wakes up with zhenya who comments that
she looks so much better than she did a
month ago this makes anya realize that
she doesn't want an uncertain
relationship where she is always scared
her partner will leave her they get into
an argument yet again and zhenya walks
away
that evening she goes to colia's house
wanting to be with a friend but collia
is so furious that he gives her an apple
and declares that their relationship as
sponsors has ended now that she has lost
weight the next morning she goes to
natasha's house but no one opens the
door she uses the neighbor's window and
a pipeline to dangerously get inside the
house it turns out that natasha and her
husband had a huge argument after which
he left the girls talk to each other and
feel a lot better the next day sergey
comes to meet anya again and apologizes
for being a bad father he also dances
with her like he used to do when she was
a kid after the two reconcile anya goes
to a fitness marathon to meet kolya she
finds him drinking a cold drink and
throws it away asserting her dominance
as his sponsor she also declares that
since he has not lost enough weight it
is her responsibility to help him no
matter what they take part in the
marathon and complete it with all their
might in the end kolya gathers enough
courage to kiss her for the first time
in her life anya realizes that obsessing
about her appearance will not make her
happy true happiness lies in accepting
yourself as you are like colya did he
always worked hard to improve his health
but was never ashamed of his appearance
anya strives to be like him subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching